hammer der woche die unterführung hammer
straße in hamburg wird nach drei
jahrzehnten planungs und bauzeit endlich
fertiggestellt aber kurz nachdem der
verkehr rollt muss ein stück des
bauwerks schon wieder abgerissen werden
eine zusätzliche brücke soll hierhin
deshalb knappert seit anderthalb wochen
der presslufthammer und die riesen
schere frisst sich durch den gerade mal
trockenen stahlbeton
die hamburger können weil solch eine
bauplanung nur noch den kopf schütteln
es ist nicht verständlich dass für sowas
steuergelder verschleudert werden also
ich bin entsetzt jetzt wieder alles
zunichte gemacht die bahnübergänge an
der hammer straße sollen seit den 80er
jahren ersetzt werden die bauarbeiten
für die neue unterführung beginnen 2015
zu diesem zeitpunkt wird bereits eine
zusätzliche schnellbahntrasse geplant
die hier verlaufen soll
trotzdem wird keine lücke für die neue s
bahn gelassen erst jetzt nachdem die
unterführung fix und fertig ist wird
wieder ein stück abgerissen der
planfeststellungsbeschluss der stadt für
die unterführung wird stur vollendet auf
den planfeststellungsbeschluss der bahn
für die neue trasse wird keine rücksicht
genommen bundesrepublikanischer planungs
er sinn in reinform jetzt schon wieder
ab weil sie festgestellt haben dass sie
wegen der ess vier dem platz da brauchen
also es ist ein unding von den
bebauungsplan hätte das irgendwie klar
sein müssen dass hat die neubau hier der
ist ja auch irgendwie vielleicht gerade
zwei jahre alt
hier noch mal parallel eine trasse
gezogen wird für die es hier geht
die stadt hamburg verweist auf den
planfeststellungsbeschluss deshalb habe
man keine rücksicht auf die baumaßnahmen
der bahn nehmen können
außerdem betont man schriftlich das
keineswegs die mauer abgerissen wird
es wird in einem kleineren vorher
definierten bereich ein stück des oberen
bereichs der vorhandenen mauer
abgetragen eine sehr feinsinnige
unterscheidung den anwohnern gegen die
unnötigen bauarbeiten einfach nur die
nerven was ich glaube ist dass sich die
leute die dafür zuständig sind das alles
gar nicht richtig angekommen
ich stehe senkrecht im bett wenn das
ding los geht jeden tag und das war es
dann auch noch nicht mit den
behinderungen denn demnächst muss die
neue unterführung an drei wochenenden
wieder für die bauarbeiten gesperrt
werden